on connaissait le fast food en bon
français la nourriture rapide et sans
art 10 et qui n'a pas toujours bonne
presse
et bien voici le slow food conçu en
réaction le mouvement est né il ya une
quinzaine d'années en italie aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup d'adeptes qui se
réunissent régulièrement
à nice olivier théron stéphane ils
avancent ils sont montés de la ville
pour voir leurs vaches
une rencontre avec celle qu'ils ont
parrainé en échange l'éleveur fourni du
fromage bien plus qu'un commerce
équitable c'est un voyage dans le goût
qui commence à tous peut-être le
souvenir d'un certain type de fromage
avec les certaines odeurs c'est l'odeur
et le goût de l'alpage le goût de
l'authentiqué
c'est un peu ça l'esprit slow food est
un mouvement parti d'italie en 1986 pour
réagir à l'ouverture d'un fast food à
rome organisé en association dans chaque
région est présent dans le monde entier
slow food et ses 83 mille bénévoles
parcours les campagnes et les marchés
pour sauver des saveurs et manger bien
parce que je vais directement au paysage
ce n'est pas un club d'élite ce n'est
pas un choix de manger dans des grands
restaurants
c'est aussi manger bon dans la
simplicité
angers bon tous les jours enseigner en
cuisinant c'est la démarche slow food de
dominique valadié le cuisinier du lycée
de salon-de-provence marché poissonnier
et mixeur géant c'est la soupe de
poisson maison pour 850 élèves pour ce
chef en casquette apprendre à aimer les
saveurs c'est une façon de se sauver de
la mal bouffe tout temps souvent les
autres si le paysan beauce vachement
bien le marchand de légumes va vendre
des légumes extraordinaire moi je vais
voir ses légumes je vais pas les
gaspiller je vais les cuisines et le
mieux possible parce que je vais vers
est vachement beau et comme je les
cuisine et le mieux possible les élèves
ont mangé le mieux possible avec autant
de philosophie le self du lycée est une
table convaincant celle en corner par
six
là tu avais un carré de porc aux pommes
et la de la blanquette format d'apurer
par exemple de terre à lui de l'île du
bien manger au lycée à la conservation
de tous les vins d'italie dans une cave
géante la croisade de slow food prend
des allures boulimique le mouvement veut
maintenant congelés 3 millions de
graines pour préserver la biodiversité